hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 11 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet there's a whole bunch of
comic-book stuff we have to talk about
really like the 2001 Space Odyssey
opening that they gave this and they
flash-forward that seems to be a big
thing which shows this season where
arrows been flashing forward to a grave
scene shield flash-forward to a space
grave scene or at least it made it seem
like there was a great is because the
Quinn jet was floating there was some
blood in the cross that slingshot wears
and that's actually who this character
is
she's slingshot from the comics the
character's real name is yo-yo Rodriguez
which is why Mac called her yo-yo at the
end of the episode now if you're
charting your Marvel timelines secret
warriors technically picks up in the
wake of Civil War so a lot of the secret
warrior stuff that's happening on the TV
show isn't gonna be exactly like it was
in the comics they're using a lot of
familiar names a lot of familiar
characters but just like the Marvel
movies change things from the comics the
TV show is gonna change a few things too
like Daisy for instance is the leader of
the secret warriors the team that she's
putting together they kept talking about
in the comics it's Nick Fury I feel like
I'm breaking format here so let's do top
5 WTF and I'll explain all the comic
book Easter eggs as we go along there's
a bunch more stuff so number 5 WTF
Coulson is totally okay torturing junior
von Strucker and I'm all on board for it
I totally hated this character I love
the idea that Baron von Strucker from
the movies had his son that he tried to
keep away a little Godfather style he
got swept up in his father's world
anyway and I loved the password we went
to Princeton together I guess all the
writers on agents of shield went to
Harvard or something but that's always a
joke the Simpsons did it too all the
time because a lot of the Simpsons
writers also wrote on the Harvard
Lampoon and it's just a stupid funny in
joke for one Ivy League college to make
fun of another Ivy League college it
seems like they got what they needed out
of him but they might still keep him
around he's still alive but he keeps
yelling you know kill me just kill me
kill me kill me he's semi-conscious but
I did love the way they used Luke's
powers to Jack his brain
one thing they did really well in this
episode was make good use of their
Inhumans people with powers like the
assault on the police station which
actually went to my other WTFs but it's
a little bit higher in the list so
number 4 WTF president Ellis from Iron
Man 3 is still in office even though it
has been a while since Iron Man 3 I'm
guessing he's in his second term by now
but the setup here is to let you know
that Coulson is officially authorized by
the US government even though they can't
acknowledge it in public they're like
yeah we can't say anything about it just
keep going no we can't make shield a
thing reading between the lines that's
them tiptoeing around Captain America
Civil War so in Captain America Civil
War shield has still fallen they're
still reeling from what happened during
Captain America Winter Soldier during
that movie so now in the world of the
movies as president Ellis sells Coulson
governments all over the place are
freaking out about Inhumans so in humans
or a global problem even though they're
not gonna be addressed in the movies was
just kind of funny like oh yeah there's
this huge problem happening no we're not
really gonna talk about it during our
250 million dollar movie but it is a
thing and that's why shield can't be a
thing because in the movie universe this
new anti-terrorism task force rises the
general Thunderbolt Ross is in charge up
whoo Talbot we actually saw at the end
of the episode or the teaser for next
week's episode has worked with in the
past Talbot is kind of like the TV show
version of Thunderbolt Ross but they did
work together in the comics too those
two characters number three WTF the
police kills slingshots
cousin in cold blood and steal the
weapons just another set up for Captain
America Civil War is that your people
wearing uniforms are just as bad
sometimes as the villains without
overtly having to be Hydra or even be
associated with them there are terrible
people no matter what good in humans bad
in humans the bad ones as we've seen or
going to be co-opted by Gideon Malick
and Hydra Coulson end of the episode
with that really awesome quote we found
a bunch of good Inhumans that makes me
wonder what Hydra has which of course
through to the ward scene but number two
WTF assault on the police station this
is how agents of shield needs to be
Inhumans using their powers creatively
together example because sling shots
range is limited to one heartbeat you
know unless they were to slow her
heartbeat down she wouldn't be able to
go for longer distances they'd give her
all those wristbands to tie everyone up
they use Joey's powers to melt all the
weapons and then you Skye is the
battering ram so there's your secret
warriors right there and they'll just
keep adding people to the team through
the season but because special effects
cost a lot of money they're not going to
do that in every single episode with the
communicator devices that they were
handing out just lets you know that
there will be more big
team-ups I don't know how big they're
gonna make that secret Warriors team but
in the comics there were never more than
seven not including Nick Fury so I'm
guessing the team isn't gonna get bigger
than that on the TV show but they
actually they did note that andrew is
still out in the wild so lash is still
running around killing other Inhumans
both good Inhumans and bad ones so he's
kind of a force of nature and this idea
of equilibrium so you have equilibrium
amongst Inhumans and then equilibrium
between them and the humans suddenly
it's sounding more and more like Star
Wars but it wouldn't be Marvel if there
weren't some Star Wars in it so on my
number one WTF of course hive now in the
body of ward makes believers of them so
I think what they're doing with his
powers is this gonna be some Spore that
allows him to control the minds of other
people so when he says make a believer
of him he probably means it in a literal
way as then he's going to force his will
upon this other inhuman in the comics
hive also has a similar ability it's
just that it's like big tentacle looking
things that attach themselves to people
that's how he controls them when hive
says that he's getting back to full
strength eating all that bra meat and
watching the Hydra highlight reels he's
probably just going to be able to spread
his spores more foot like across an
entire city so imagine you get this big
battle at the end of the season between
the secret warriors in hydras Inhumans
hives ability would allow him to control
everyone no matter whose side that
they're on so that's what he means when
he's talking about getting back to full
strength
let me know in the comments though what
was your favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think is gonna
happen with hi vs. secret warriors do
you think that he's gonna end up
mind-controlling Daisy and all the
secret warriors - how are they gonna
take him down because he could just
inhabit someone else's body that's all
he needs to do it's not like he's
permanently trapped in Ward's body but
if you guys didn't see the Captain
America Civil War teaser I posted this
morning
there's a giant civil war trailer
posting tomorrow morning I'll totally
make a video for it so be sure to
subscribe to get that if there's any
Marvel bonus videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments and I know I didn't talk about
Fitz and Simmons too much but I really
do like what they're doing with those
characters I do like the direction that
that is headed why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for that Captain America Civil War
teaser and you can click here for the
Game of Thrones red band trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
five I'll see you guys tonight
you